do i look like i'm covered in blue  wildebeests  probably because i've got big news after  more than six years of feeding brains  the curiosity box is growing mel science  has joined our family this is our  biggest step yet in our mission to help  brains everywhere because the curiosity  box has always been for everyone but now  we've got what i believe are the best  science kits for kids they're seriously  fun but also they're serious  as for the curiosity box every box will  now come with a series of videos from me  about each item and some of the wackier  ideas i've been wanting to do for years  will finally be possible so to celebrate  we're offering 50 off your first box  with code family you can join our  growing community at curiositybox.com or  mel science.com curiositybox stay  curious and as always thanks for  watching